et voici le maître de maison qui nous
reçoit si gentiment bonjour irait très
bien merci
je te remercie de non ça va comme ça
j'espère que c'est pas de faire trop de
dérangements parce que nous sommes
quelques centaines de mails y ait un
choix est le bienvenu au contraire mais
ça m'est égal
avis aux apprentis comédiens qui croient
qu'il suffit de se laisser guider par
son génie quand on ment sur scène vrai
que yves montand malgré ses succès au
music hall et au cinéma travaille et je
crois que tu t'y mets l'école comme un
petit gars sanquer oui absolument il
faut reprendre tout à zéro et repartir
du bon pied si on veut
je n'ai pensé durant ces sept mois que
théâtre théâtre théâtre et c'est
évidemment très passionnant parce que
c'est tout à fait notre travail que la
chanson n'a absolument rien à voir et
c'est je me rends compte que c'est très
très très dur
comme j'aime quand vous déteste mais
surtout ne laissez jamais les gens
indifférents parce que ça sonne quand
vous payez comptant c'est-à-dire fait
état sur des métiers d'année